it's just the kind of video where you
need a lot of better the support
it's time I found the worst cringe
related to put apply and I'm going to
react to it I might not make it out
alive we're just gonna have to see named
dark edge blood sword and it's already
the coolest name I have ever heard
weapons soul katana dude you had a dark
edge blood sword but your weapon is a
soul katana now you're just being
ridiculous
favorite movie The Dark Knight of course
dark edge blood sword the Hedgehog hey
[ __ ]
excuse me it's dark edge blood sword
here
no the Hedgehog odd right there okay
cool
his friends are Shaggy 2 dope shrek and
pewdiepie Thank You dark edge blood
sword my my good old friend my good old
pal
my heart is a black tormented hole of
emptiness how are you do not steal dark
and blood sword
do not [ __ ] steal dark edge blood
source material bio it's a slipknot on
his hat that's awesome dude
PewDiePie haircut
[ __ ] sake man it's the same one like
people get might I've noticed people
getting my tattoos and stuff and this is
like why why so this is a Facebook post
dumb PewDiePie fans are tricked into
burning themselves high stag burn for
pubes I Love You Felix
you were always there for me and now I'm
gonna be here for you I don't know
what's more cringe this pose or the fact
that people think it's real honestly
it's so obviously fake you just look up
someone that bright okay you know what
see if I can find that same image oh wow
there's image how about that it's from
Afghanistan I guess I have fans in
Afghanistan I don't know man
what do you think about what do you
think about that easily I agree 100%
with what he just said
pitbull hey poop I love your videos and
and what pitbull oh my god now this is
some cringe
prepare yourself this was when I lived
in Italy and some guy that was on
holiday in Italy came by our house my
girlfriend's mom opened the door and was
like they said fan out there you have to
do and I was like okay you know why it
says after some wedding because I didn't
want to [ __ ] go out I was like this
is crazy what the [ __ ] are they doing
here don't get me wrong if I meet you
anywhere else literally anywhere else we
can be taking a piss on a urinal
I'd be fine meeting you but don't come
to my house it's so wrong
oh my god this is long ago very long ago
2013 like I wanted my shirt nice to meet
you my admitting it too back then
everything was so new and this is the
first time this happened to me I didn't
know how to react that's why this video
is so cringy channel and I created a
video asking girls to oh but put it
comments to ask you some questions that
nobody comes oh really yeah
on the foot yeah that's uh he was gonna
interview me but he was really bad at
interviewing that one second question
yeah oh you can tell how [ __ ] tired I
am here dog second second question yeah
um look I'm [ __ ] done ahead yeah um I
I still get I yeah I guess I still
cannot see the question obviously yeah
I'm sweating now this is legit crunching
me out man oh this is a good one
awkwardly handshake executed by a coda
to Brian and Peter pie and some
middle-aged men hold the left trigger
you that was awful
I started to my face is just like oh god
this is gonna be on the internet forever
now great yeah
see this is why you should never do a
handshake and anything that's being
recorded that you can't control
now let go go go never give up oh never
let go never gave up you let go you
so
don't don't know I never asked for this
you know I never asked for this oh I was
good at this reading some YouTube
comments oh look there's one right in
here
could you play sucks it applies gay why
do I do to make people think I'm gay I
really don't get it I can't I can't
old Peter private iou's I can't I'm not
touching that [ __ ] that's in the past
like you know anything would old pin
pipe it they're the [ __ ] worst Oh
shoo shoo old Peter Pan videos a Slee do
something do something about the videos
I still get ad revenue from okay that's
enough cringe can we all just take a
moment and support hashtag burn for pins
but all these crunchy pretty private
images I don't know how much longer I'm
gonna make it alright
hashtag burn for boots let's make it
happen let's make that [ __ ] trend that's
it for me for now though leave like me
enjoy watching and as always I see Bruce
tomorrow with a new video sheäôs
impressed
scares has come out as homosexual we
reached out to stairs or a comment about
the situation and I'm gay I told my
parents I'm gay alright and my mom is
super homophobic mom both like your mom
and my dad actually like grab my balls
and they both sincerely think I'm gay
now oh my god I just I can't [ __ ]
believe it and I'll see other piece I'm
gay